well this year we're forecast to grow
faster than most of our other advanced
economy peers which is a good thing and
also if you look at the labor market
which is thing i focus on because it's
something that impacts real people
whether it's regard to the number of
people in work the number of people
unemployed i think there the data is
incredibly strong the uk has exceeded
all expectations for what might happen i
think thanks in part to our plan for
jobs and that's something that i'm
really delighted to see how about
compared with where we were before the
pandemic the size of the economy i think
if you look at that then what you'll see
is you know broadly we're in line with
other countries now of course as we've
discussed in the past there are
different ways to measure this which
slightly confuses things but broadly we
have almost recovered pre-crisis gdp but
i mean actually quarterly numbers we're
still 2.1 percent this is latest numbers
just today we're 2.1 below pre-crisis
levels france is only 0.1 percent
germany only 1.1 the u.s is already 1.4
beyond where it was before the pandemic
do you guys have actually kind of a
laggard when it comes to our recovery i
think you're using the courtly numbers
as the ons because they're the
comparable well if you if you look at
what the ons said today i think they
also focused on the monthly numbers
which show that we're only point six
percent
terrible
gdp and then what you have to look at is
the different ways to measure this and
again as independent commentators have
pointed out in the past whether you look
at nominal or real gdp does make a
difference the way we measure public
sector output in the uk what's happening
in our schools and our hospitals is
different to all those other countries
that you mentioned and because obviously
we we've had quite a disruption in all
of these things over the past year
that's impacted our numbers differently
to how all those countries other
countries calculate their figures so i
mean you you dispute that the uk is the
slowest in terms of its recovery from
this pandemic in the in the g7 well if
you look at actually the forecast from
the oecd we're forecast to grow faster
than where we are now yeah i think you
know what we're talking about here are
our point six percent of gdp that we are
below currently we're forecast to
recover lower than every other g7
right now but if you look at labour
market performance
i'm talking specifically about gdp
numbers but i think it's well i think
it's hard to compare apples to apples on
gdp and that's why you're right on the
numbers that you've presented but we are
slower in terms of our recovery from the
on that particular measure i think we're
broadly in line but what i'd say is on
another measure of gdp if you look at
nominal gdp and there are good reasons
to look at nominal gdp we're actually
ahead of all those countries and second
only to the us it doesn't seem like you
just want to choose the statistic though
well i think it's i think it's known
it's not either i think you can look at
either statistic all i'd say is it's
right to look at both i think it's
totally fair for you to say look on this
measure this is where you are i think
it's reasonable for me to say well hang
on there are some problems with that
measure because we'd measure things
differently to other countries
reasonable that those things are apples
to apples if you do that we actually are
better than all those countries with the
exception of the us and ahead
of all of them and then if you look at
something else which people will really
understand because i think the reality
is nominal real gdp how is all this
calculated is a bit a bit technical if
you talk about
yeah but if you look at the real economy
what do people really look at and i
think rightly they'll look at jobs for
example
how many people are in work how many
people are out of work compare that to
what other countries are doing and what
you see is a we've exceeded all
expectations about what would happen we
have lower unemployment rates than all
those countries pretty much that you
mentioned and more people in work now
for several months in a row and that's
fantastic because that makes a real
difference to people's lives and also
they look at their standards of living
and you know there is you know people
are facing a squeeze at the moment
prices going up real earnings are
certainly kind of not looking quite as
promising as they they were previously
do you understand the frustration that
people might feel when they see the
stories about mps and second jobs right
now
i think
people will be looking around and i
think fair enough that they will be
concerned about cost of living and
that's why we've taken action to help
address those things we've set up a
household about what was going on in
parliament with mps as well well i think
first one you know how are we actually
directly helping people and we're
directly helping them by setting up a
half a billion pound household support
fund which will mean that millions of
our most vulnerable families will get a
little bit of extra help with bills over
the winter period we've got a range of
other measures in place to help with
energy bills in particular and in the
recent budget not only do we freeze fuel
duty we we cut taxes for those on the
lowest incomes a universal credit taper
rate which will be an enormous uplift to
millions of vulnerable families as well
as increasing the national living wage
so as a government we're committed to
helping people with the cost of living
do you think mps earn enough
i mean certainly those mp's pay is set
by an independent body do you think it's
enough obviously it's set by an
independent body and we should take
those recommendations is it enough
though to for them to represent their
constituencies to feel like they don't
necessarily need to try and earn
hundreds of thousands of pounds
elsewhere yeah i i think people will
have different motivations for doing
what they do
the pay is set by an independent body
that's absolutely right and with regard
to
second jobs there's an independent
process that we have that's set by
parliament that governs all of those
things and it's absolutely right that
process is followed to the letter now
look on the broader point and just
reflecting uh over recent events
i think for us as a government it's fair
to say that we need to do better than we
did last week and we know that